but if we could skip that line avoid  death avoid Interstellar uh kind of have  the secret to these Advanced  Technologies and to advance knowledge  that to me is the Pinnacle of what Homo  sapiens could achieve when you look at  this when you hear these complaints and  and so forth people being skeptic do you  feel like Skeptics have a point I've  studied Russian and Chinese high  technology for my whole career dgap or  whatever the hell they are I mean we  call them uaps we really don't know what  they are are they here to basically  change us are they more of a control  mechanism we have tons of questions zero  answers I think science has a huge huge  way ahead of them I mean it's going to  be very very difficult but I don't think  we have options except to investigate  this but it's clearly not human